House Republicans are trying to put the
finishing touches on a plan for
immigration reform after being
blindsided by President Trump earlier in
the day chief congressional
correspondent Mike Emanuel is in
Washington to tell us what happened and
maybe what's next a chaotic day as
president Trump nearly spiked a
carefully negotiated immigration reform
compromise I certainly wouldn't assign
them oh ma what is the bill I mean I
need a bill that gives this country
tremendous border security I have to
have that that comment shocked House
Republican leaders who are planning to
measure support for the compromise
package today but call that off a
moderate Republican in the middle of the
talks sounded stunned we are waiting the
president clarify his comments we've
negotiated the four pillars deal his
deal a senior White House official later
clarified saying the president misspoke
about this legislation in fact the
Republican compromise bill checks a lot
of boxes 25 billion dollars to build the
president's border wall and catch and
release and the Visa Lottery system and
it would allow the so-called dreamers to
apply for a six year renewable visas I
think it's a very good bill I think this
is a very good compromise and this can
make law House GOP leadership has been
planning votes next week on that
compromise in a more conservative plan
from Judiciary Chairman Bob Goodlatte
Democrats seem to enjoy the chaos my
suspicion is they don't know what the
schedule is for the week to come you
mean the president complicated the
situation with the with the comment I
just I just yeah I just don't find the
shocking
president Trump blamed Democrats for
illegal immigrant parents being
separated from their children on Twitter
and on camera continuing the war of
words I hate the children being taken
away the Democrats have to change their
law that's their law that's the
Democrats law we can change it tonight
we can change it right now he's using
children whether they're dreamers or
whether there's no children at the
border now for political purpose it's
shameful late today a White House
spokesman went on the record to say
president Trump fully supports both
bills the house is expected to consider
next week
the official concluding the president
would sign either bill into law
Brett Mike Manuel out on the hill Mike
thanks